i am literally trembling because outside
the store is the neil degrasse tyson
damn he'll be back believe it or not he
has agreed to come in and sit down with
me and talk about space and i'm losing
my mind i'm so excited and i'm so
nervous let's do it
welcome to the universe
hello everybody i am elisa kelly i am
the astrologer here at the drew
barrymore show and i am here with my new
friend
neil degrasse tyson who does not who is
not an astrologer that that is
a very true fact why not question number
one sure did anyone ever think that what
you do is the work of an astrologer was
ever someone like oh in the old days
when you would just say oh i'm in a
straw number they'll say oh tell me my
star sign or this sort of thing and then
but when you say astrophysicist that
yeah yeah
right i i don't have that nobody can
change this
yeah i don't have that title i try to
take charge of your own destiny which is
harder to do if you're always looking up
thinking that the universe is
controlling you well i don't think that
the universe controls us i think that
what we see is a beautiful
projection
of self and we have these incredible
archetypes that allow us to see
ourselves as these multi-dimensional
people as the universe and the cosmos
are multi-dimensional wasn't the greek
and roman religions which we today call
mythologies wasn't that exactly this yes
think about it yeah there was a god of
this and and the gods were not perfect
they get angry sometimes and they get
they get jealous they get thick and so
everything that we
care about being human was manifest
in these external forces it gave them a
pathway to make sense out of things that
didn't otherwise make sense in their
life there's just poseidon who got angry
with me that's why i threw some waves on
my feet
so i'm in complete agreement with you we
we believe it or not we align
in a planetary way do we align we do
do you know that your sagittarius rising
be honest no
well for our viewers at home um
can i tell you what sagittarius
before we sat down you asked me what my
star sign was correct i think you did
and my response well of course it's very
public because i'm a public figure but
if you didn't otherwise know and you
were an astrologer
why should i have to tell you you should
just no oh no no no that's not how it
works why not i'm not a psychic oh okay
all the people are psychic
okay so i'm i'm born in october i know
you're a libra i'm born in october
october what uh fifth i know you're a
libra but i also know your sagittarius
rising or at least i think there's some
birth info that's out there for you it
might not be accurate but you really
strike me as a sagittarius rising okay
can i tell you but that wouldn't be the
case if you didn't otherwise know that i
was born in october because sagittarius
is adjacent to that so well the rising
sign is actually which zodiac which
zodiac sign not constellation which
zodiac sign was coming up from the
eastern horizon at your exact moment of
birth
so it's another piece of the puzzle
because in astrology we have all
different zodiac signs with the planet
that's part of the challenge is because
you have so many
forces operating on the conclusions that
you draw it's up to you the interpreter
that's mix and match to find something
that might be relevant or feel important
to the on the receiving end
of that commentary so
for that reason i have much less
confidence in it than you do because
it's
given that level of interpretation
will
five different astrologers give you that
same answer probably not no because i'm
the best
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god
okay i think that went well i think
we're bff he's such a libra i think that
we really connected i think his sag
rising really saw my leo son
welcome to the universe